[Aplausos]
bonita todos
meu nome é santos acho que estão aqui
todos por curiosidade
penso eu cristina vencerá informáticos
na sala não há não é intocável
[Risadas]
então é assim eu venho aqui com este
painel porque achei que era interessante
trazê-los para perceberem os três tipos
de profissionais na minha área
eu sou considerada uma área uma área uma
ética ela a quer porque é porque eu
estou a trabalhar como empregado comum
paga após vender
saiba os ataques neste momento são por
voltarem porque que não optei por ser
uns curso muito simples de ser vivo que
era mais fácil eu entrar por caminhos do
branco e estarão os meus conhecimentos
para selar a paramount lado do paulo
o mal que me trazendo quando ele voltou
a 0
eu se calhar se fosse escura moleque não
ia gastar hoje porque ter medo de
mostrar a minha cara
provavelmente o meu trabalho não ia ser
contributivo é um prócer lado não me ter
nava
vamos mostrar hoje sim quando vocês
pensam em a quer que vocês pensam
um criminoso não é alguém que está para
embalar irão um sistema alguém que está
para roubar a algum tipo de informação
no meu caso eu preferi pensar o
contrário
se eu tenho esse conhecimento porque eu
não posso usufruir lo
eles eram uma a uma instituição
contratem contratem porque eu sou boa
eu posso defender de um possível ataque
eu posso pôr o vosso sistema mais seguro
porque não
foi isto o pensamento que eu tive que há
tempos li uma frase que dizia o seguinte
um dia descobri que estava dentro do
sistema e civis e bombeiros
isso fez sentido
realmente eu talvez no sistema se
quisesse roubar coisas se quisesse
roubar informação
eu poderia fazer o patê qual a
informação consistem nos nossos
computadores telemóveis klaus
o valor dessa informação
vocês já pensaram nisso a tecval o vosso
nível igual ou no cartão de crédito
quanto é que vale a vossa informação
familiar
na semana passada fui dar uma formação é
uma empresa e quanto antes lá chegar
leão do ano vão levar o nome única e
exclusivamente o nome das pessoas que
estavam presentes na formação e quando
achei isso não quero que ninguém se
apresenta centenas todos e vamos começar
a informação quando conseguem estar
datas de nascimento
familiares amigos e pessoas começaram a
ficar assustadas e eu disse isso foram
vocês que me deram eu simplesmente me
limitei a fazer uma trabalho
foram vocês como passaram essa
informação você chega em que eu as
informações da pública têm um carinho
sobre isso vocês facilitamos a vida das
nossas coisas que nós queremos é fácil é
psicologia humana fácil de enganar uma
pessoa que está enfrentando um
computador
aliás o problema da assembléia é sempre
quem cometer os erros que em facilitar a
vida dos outros jogadores são
fantásticos
vocês ajudaram imenso o trabalho mas
neste caso
continuo a dizer é óptimo lado bom
porque acho que o meu trabalho pode ser
um contributo não quer ser uma criminosa
e não quero que vocês olhem por mim digo
que eu sou criminal por roubo coisas não
é contribuir para a sociedade quer
contribuir para usar o conhecimento que
fazer lembrar sequer a minha promoção
tem um valor que não penso em casar em
vez de pública quanto férias boa arroz
público só daqui uma semana que quando
eu chego por quê porque assim está
resguardado possíveis assuntos da minha
casa
isso é uma informação o tempo a formação
do negócio
vocês publicam não sei se aqui
empresários ou menos 1 até ficar uma
volta extra de dizer isto a melhor porta
ruim dawa melhor sistema informático
três papéis em cima da mesa
fácil né do empregado a limpeza pode
apanhar e vender o segredo
afinal não é só a segurança digital
nossa física também é comprometida
não é preciso pensar mais havia a frente
que é por que no dia a dia alguém escuso
com bosco no não posso sair no café
então joana com metástase ou se cada
pessoa fica pensar e conheça você tem um
cargo importante entre uma empresa e não
sabe muito bem que já aconteceram tantas
pessoas
no dia seguinte a pessoa está outra vez
continuam a conversar
o produto fazia uma só com o mercado
ficar assim o dono da empresa não sabe
muito bem porque não foi trabalho de um
laker foram conselho verón simplesmente
tipo só de nos enganar
queremos assim nos sistemas
eu sou preta ainda nesses temas ou não
depende da facilidade como vocês me
ajudam no dia a dia
não é só esta parte como é óbvio
existe uma parte digital que é preciso
passar e exige muito trabalho não é como
nos filmes
não acreditem que só estalar os dedos e
está tudo feito
eu estava muito quente e trabalhar menos
horas
não é mas não é bem assim
acho que quando vocês precisarem
efetivamente a pensarem numa maca e
precisarem de romeu e contratarem com
vai ser uma mais valia
vamos ver que afinal anos houve uma
criminosa e que posso contribuir para
uma melhoria não só do digital mas de
formação pessoal porque isso é
importante
se calhar é que ocorre no início ninguém
pensava o valor da que a informação tem
ninguém pensou até o dia de hoje se
calhar é minha formação pode ser vendida
facilmente porque isso acontece é que há
uns tempos de algumas notícias que o
espaço arte e os jornais eram vendidas
no mercado negro
nunca ninguém pensou o vovô conquistou
em toda a gente no 10
aqui eu posso ordem e o irmão que acham
que eu ia conseguir tem idéia do que ia
conseguir
vocês têm o cima eu e as vossas passou
tempo demais a uma coisa ninguém nas ao
trabalho de alterar uma passou por que
chegam ao aeroporto precisam desligar a
wifi potter na internet e ver onde eu
vou viajar quando eu e meu clown vão
colocar meu pessoal qual é passou a
tomar vão colocar as farc usam pra turma
também praticam esses atos não só vem a
facilitar a visa não só a nível passou
estou falando um modo geral para que
percebam que este tema eu posso colocar
essa questão à espera de uma cena épica
não é
castro todos vós aqui os lados nos
trouxe computador evitar tocar nos
telemóveis adiantam viu num cantinho
para que não fosse muito visível para
que ninguém
uma coisa assinava porque eu quero
trabalhar durante muito tempo mas é um
carinho assim quando se entrar nesta
área há quatro anos atrás quando começa
efetivamente a trabalhar é percebi que a
área era desconhecido em portugal nunca
se ouviu falar num a quer
posso dizer que nós somos cerca de 50 em
portugal ba
sim é trabalhar neste lar vão pros
outros cursos não fazia aí também não
quero muito vencer que às vezes até dava
jeito mas não são cerca de 50 e posso
dizer que nós todos prestamos um serviço
assim ela uma maneira ou de outra porque
somos efetivamente acreditados para
trabalhos
as empresas precisam nós ninguém se
lembra que nós existimos que a pena é
triste para mim perceber que muitas
vezes olham para mim peso não é
criminosa e eu não sou eu tenho o
conhecimento nos boa mal pode ser um
contributo para a sociedade quer
contribuir para que vocês não contratem
uma empresa precisa de uma pessoa quanto
pra ver se efetivamente está surdo ou
não
quando vocês aqui tem alguém da
segurança a trabalhar a não ser o
próprio físico segurança digital nas
vossas empresas não há respostas
é termos um mau e duas 2 mas já não é
mau numa ponta e com um bar sempre sou o
cara mais eu sou viagem não conseguir
ver mas mesmo assim nós não podemos num
quero que nos meteram copos existem
essas três coisas sabem por que aquelas
são distinguidos simples eu sou encarada
como branco porque eu tenho um
contributo para a minha empresa e não só
temos o escuro quando eu digo escura por
tudo
não importa quem é que nós vamos
aguardar não importa o juiz que nós
vamos provocar
nós queremos destruir não se importa um
colapso que está do outro avanço sim
porque os destroem uma equipa de
segurança muitas vezes a trabalhar de
noite sem recurso a nossa segurança nós
somos essenciais entre aspas quando há
um ataque a toda a gente se lembra que
não desistimos
quando tudo corre bem nós somos os
espetáculos os gatos laboratório
emitidos no pior lugar tomar quando as
coisas correm mal
somos nós os culpados sempre porque nós
estamos lá porque nós estamos
enfrentando um computador com 500
monitores mas ninguém quer saber nós só
quando há um ataque neste aqui e de
estragar a vida porque alguém tenta
simplesmente destruir o prazer de atacar
de ver as coisas acontecerem dizer que é
fantástico é mans destrói a vida de
muita gente pois temos aqui um cinzento
que há uma única vez para eu fazer o
vinil mal se eu queria ir mais além em
toul conter um crime inserir mais abaixo
não estou satisfeito
então eu tento equilibrar as coisas que
é ok eu vou destruir o que vou fazer se
ele chegar à empresa e dizer olha que
vai estar o dono da verdade
está aqui o relatório tem arestas e
estas estas poucas corrigi-las eu fiz o
trabalho porque são um perigo mas podem
contratar a seguir
então eu uma o que não é minha
é entre estes três mundos destacar hoje
dizer que foi o dinheiro porque o filme
plástica não a própria amy procura
eternamente e não encontrou em cima hoje
procurei nome próprio por nome covatti
não encontrei lado nenhum
falta de segurança são raros os que são
licenciados são os ratos de laboratório
e nem quer saber de nós então quando vem
cá e wireless pronto em cerca na minha
procura e eu vou sair aí falar também
com o tema não é sim muito a minha praia
por que que eu vou falar a respeito mas
respeito o que na minha área é que o
pessoal a pensar que nos marca falar a
respeito
como assim seus novos patrões são
criminosos
pois foi isso que vocês pensaram certo
quando viram o nome de uma rapariga por
cima que vocês pensaram podem dizer não
só vêm não só que ela dizer
primeiro vieram por curiosidade porque
nunca viram uma mulher nesta área
se calhar porque nunca contactaram com
nenhuma tão perto e depois porque a quer
como assim uma criminosa que vai expor a
sua cara
será que sintam tão importante a e não
sou criminosa e não quero atacar
facebook no país são isso também é
comemorada na fazer direita e só voz
milhares de projetos
acreditem que quer vê-la da oposição
entraram e não foi isso que eu preciso
dizer que eu vá fazer isso não é minha
praia
isso não é uma outra área sim eu
respeito o trabalho
por isso a classe c ética seguir uma
corrida tática seguir não ser má não ser
criminosa porque você só passem por mim
na rua ele olha que ela tem emprego fixo
e fora do comum mas é das poucas que eu
conheço porque normalmente nós temos
todos um carimbo e ninguém quer falar
conosco ninguém quer
karen nada porque é bom ficar assim
alguma coisa porque eu vou roubar alguma
coisa não ligam os vossos nomes no iene
não digam porque coisa vou correr mal
conseguir vos olha que era que a riac
que foi o que a renda do agente é e
tocava primeiro poeta chris quase
ninguém mas quem é que fui eu quando
você for um monte de coisa que eu coloco
o canal pessoal
foi pastor é que usa em todo o lado
provavelmente irá se eu agora que vai
seguir como como agora trabalhar né isso
é má e depois vocês vão poder fazer uma
queixa na polícia dizer senhor vamos nos
lados mas o gol foi minha porque eu era
informação mas ela é criminosa não é tão
grande responsável por tudo o que
acontece em volta que vai à casa de
jantar pai na passo da internet google
maps aliar-se certeza que esse lugar
aqui também
de volta à linha embora bem cansado mas
não faz mal a ninguém podem uma casa
ligar se à vontade porque não quer saber
das nossas vidas
garantidamente ser a única coisa que
quer saber do meu trabalho porque eu com
pagam que mantenha a minha instituição
censura tenha sempre um convite para
trabalhar com a saída da defesa que isso
faça atualmente minha equipa gosta de
trabalhar comigo que acima de tudo
respeito à minha profissão eu não quero
ser criminoso não quer ser conhecido
como uma criminosa quer ser conhecido a
10 anos trabalha na área de segurança
que é uma época que nunca ninguém me viu
trabalhar aqui mas gostava convincente
para ti para poder buscar dinheiro e
errava da coisa porque eu sei que eu
tinha muita idéia é favorito e cima tudo
que gostem deste mundo
unido e que tenham curiosidade em
perceber um caminho mais porque sad
portista acredita em mim
tem muito divertido trabalhar na
história o rei em cima de base que
inventei essa uma testemunha chamou
temos de atacar também
espero que tenham gostado se quiserem
contactar vai ser difícil mas vou estar
por cá se quiserem fazer algo de pronta
e espero que tenha uma boa noite e
curiosidades estejam à vontade para
aproveitar obrigando a minha empregada
[Aplausos]
[Música]